again this is okay
yes okay great so welcome back everybody
today we're going to start off with the
talk by uh
thanks please sir
thank you very much so thanks to all the
organizers for inviting me to this
excellent conference in this beautiful
place
repeatedly i didn't make it to berkeley
but i enjoyed listening to the to the
talks
previous days so today i would like to
give a talk about my recent
work with asaph now it's not very recent
because we started it several years ago
but
it took some time and also a small baby
uh appeared in asaf's home so
things got a bit delayed but finally
it's published
it's just appeared in gaffa israel
seminar
and also it's on archive so if you want
to
to go and see the details then it's
available at archive in almost
in the final version
so the starting point is
that you have two independent
f valued random vectors and f in
the whole torque stands for a separable
bandwidth space
let me just mention that this
separability
isn't a big deal this is mainly to
get rid of all measurability problems
so when you add two independent
random vectors you would like to have
their sum
also being a measurable random variable
and inseparable bandwidth space it works
perfectly
but actually most of the problems
make sense in finite dimensional spaces
or
can be easily adapted even to
some standards non-separable banner
spaces like
say small l infinity so
it's just a pure technicality to avoid
talking about some measurability
problems all the way
so now the trivial observation is that
if you
this two random vectors are integrable
meaning that your first moments are
finite
then the pointwise triangle inequality
which holds for every point of the
vector space f
implies after integration the following
in a coordinate so you just integrate
both sides
you choose the optimal set or
some sequence of sets that's going
to to give you the infimum and this is
what you have so this is the trivial
bound
and basically most of
this research with asaf started from the
question
to what extent can this type of bound be
reversed that was our starting point
and let me just mention that
so when you look at this reasoning here
you don't use independence in
any way right so it's enough to have
just two
random vectors x and y that live on the
same probability space and you can do
the same
argument but of course you need to
assume something to be able
to reverse this inequality
paying of course some price in terms of
some
multiplicative universal constant
hopefully and you need to assume
something because
you need to exclude the possibility that
x is just identical to y on the whole
probability space
but non-constant okay if this happens
the left-hand side will be zero and the
right hand side it will be non-zero
possibilities then you are in table
right and there is no hope for
inverting this bound so independence is
a natural assumption
to exclude just having
trivial zero left hand side here unless
the both variables are just constant
okay so this is a natural question and
because
this first part of reasoning can be done
without
the independence assumption once you get
the reverse bound it gives you also some
understanding in terms of
what happens when you have two random
vectors x and y
that are not necessarily independent
so we can take then independent copies
of x and y
which themselves are not independent and
you can
deduce from this reverse bound and from
this trivial bound
that actually the independent case
in a way majorizes the generic situation
you have
any couple of x and y you
choose their independent copies
and you observe from this reverse
boundary from this trivial bound
that this expression for
arbitrary x and y is dominated
by the same expression up to some
constant with
their independent copies replacing
x and y okay so this is a natural
question
to study such quantities
and now i i want to have some pretext
to say that this fits to the subject of
our conference so we can pretend
that this has something to do with
concentration for the following reason
you may construct a new
f valued random vector just by taking a
mixture
of x and y with weights one-half
one-half
so you make a new random vector
by defining its distribution in the
following way
and then obviously this expression
is two times expectation
that minus little set
and therefore the inequality
that we deal with can be expressed the
the right hand side here can be
expressed
in terms of the concentration properties
of this random vector set so somehow
you look at the joint concentration of x
and y
by taking their mixture and asking how
well
can this concentrate around a single
point okay so this is
somehow connected to the idea of
concentration
and this side tells you something about
the joint concentration of x and y
and the left-hand side tells you
something about concentration of
x around y and vice versa okay so this
is
this expressions have something to do
with concentration
in spirit okay so now uh
for a separate verbanak space we define
a number of geometric moduli
and each of them is of some interest
and i will just briefly describe them
so to start with given some
parameter p that is positive and usually
it's at least one
you define little bp of the
banner space as an infini as the infimum
over those constant beta for which
this inequality holds whenever you have
a valid integrable random
integrable with peace power random
vectors okay so whenever
the left-hand side makes sense whenever
you have enough integrability
you just ask what is the optimal
constant working for
and a couple of independent random
variables okay so this is a legitimate
question
what i showed you before is the same
question
just for p equal to one okay so now we
can ask the same question for p
uh differing from one and
the use of letter b in this notation
comes
from some metric geometry from romanian
alexander of geometry
and it refers to the geometric barrier
center in the context of hadamard spaces
and the name was invented by assaf and
to me barry center somehow is associated
with a different thing
but but it has some
some good explanation in terms of
assaf's previous research in romanian
alexander of
geometry so this is why the letter b
appears here and now
uh that was actually where we started
uh we assaf was interested in finding
the answer what is b1
what is the optimal constant
in the reversal of this inequality
for exponent one so
actually it's very easy to prove that
from p equal to one you can prove this
inequality with constant
three and for p greater than one
you can prove it with constant two times
three halves in power p and this is like
few lines using only jensen's inequality
and triangle inequality this is simple
what is interesting is that this is also
optimal
and somehow optimality of this constant
is
much less obvious at some other
conference i
showed with details the construction of
an example showing that and this concept
actually is optimal
i will not repeat this because i know
that some part of the audience
have seen the proof and the way it's in
the paper i will just briefly sketch
how you make an example of the banner
space
showing that you cannot beat this
constant
so basically the idea is uh that you try
to imitate
the metric space that comes from the
graph distance on the by bipartite
graph so you have imagine that you have
a graph
uh with n wide vertices and and
black vertices and the distance between
any distinct wide vertices is two
the distance between any distinct black
vertices is two
and the distance between any white
vertex
to the arbitrary black vertex is equal
to one
so this is exactly what happens when you
have a bipartite graph
on one side you have white vertices on
the other side you have black vertices
and edges go only between white
between all white and all black vertices
this is a complete bipartite graph
so in your if you look on this graph for
a shortest path between white and black
where it is vertex it will be just the
edge connecting them
and if they are of the same color you
must first
pass to the other part of the graph and
then come back okay so the
graph distance is equal to two okay but
this is
a metric space and
there are good reasons to investigate
this metric space
in context of this question but how you
make it a banner space how you embed it
into a banner space
so any metric space can be embedded into
little l infinity every finite metric
space so
you just embed this by prioritized
graph with the
graph distance and then
you try to put it in a nice way to to
get some symmetry so that computations
are possible
and then you calculate everything and it
doesn't work
basically that's the starting point
and then you notice that
if you put it in nice enough way
all vertices of this graph after
embedding
into little l infinity may lay
on the on the same hyperplane
you can take for example the hyperplane
consisting of all points whose sum of
coordinates is equal to zero
and when you do that trig you can
prove that if you want to
[Music]
to optimize this side with that
that needs to have a lot of symmetry
between coordinates
because all everything is symmetric you
can use the enzyme inequality
showing that if you look for the optimal
z in this quantity
it's enough to look at that which has
first n coordinates equal and
remaining n coordinates also equal
but with an minus sign
so if for first
n coordinates of that you have some
value
you the remaining and coordinates of
that will have
value negative view in this way
you restrict the sets that you need to
consider
to a very small subset and then proving
the inequality
proving that you you cannot get a better
constant than
uh three for p equal to one or in
general that you cannot beat
this quantity two times three over half
in power p
is relatively simple okay so that's the
basic idea
you first take the pipeartic graph with
the graph metric then you try to
embed embedded just to get into the
banner space setting and then
you realize that your example doesn't
work in the l
infinity as a whole but then you just
cut
this l infinity with some hyperplane and
then it works
okay so that that's basically and then
you pass
with n which is the number of vertices
in this
bipartite graph to infinity and you
prove asymptotically that you cannot
beat discounts
so that's the basic idea of the
construction it's a bit laborious
to show it in that in detail so because
i
i have already showed this at some other
conference
and many people from the audience saw it
i i don't want to
to bother with repeating this
okay so that was our starting point
but on the way to getting the
understanding
that this is the right constant actually
assaf and i got annoyed for a while
because we tried some other counter
examples and they didn't work
whenever we had some favorite space and
we
tried to prove that well you can do
better than
you cannot do better than constant three
for p equal to one
we failed so of course we started to
think why we failed all the way along
along trying to to find the counter
example to find the example
showing the optimality of this constant
3 here
and we realized that this has something
to do with the geometry of the space
and we tried to prove some positive
results showing that
if you assume something more about this
bundle space
f then you can get a better constant in
this inequality okay so
that's another part of our research
after realizing that this is the optimal
concept and providing an example
indicating that we looked for some other
approach
to get some better consent under some
additional assumptions okay so now let
me
sketch some other
geometric moduli that we chanced upon
in our research so this site is
sponsored by
the letter m which stands for mixture
and now we look for the same inequality
but instead of the arbitrary smaller set
from the space f we just look at the
average
the the arithmetic mean of expectations
of x and y
so here it's natural in this context to
assume that p
is greater equal to 1 because then it
ensures the existence of the expectation
this is
this is a natural setting and now you
ask for the same inequality
but restricting your attention
to a particular choice of that
equal to the average of expectation x
and
expectation of y and of course you can
rephrase it using this mixture random
variable reset
that i discussed before then this
average of expectation is clearly the
expectation of
that you can rephrase this inequality in
this way
and there is an obvious observation just
because this is the special case of the
choice of
little set always you have this in a
call it okay
so that's another natural question that
you can ask
and we we made some research in this
direction i will
briefly state some results in a moment
and then another term is roundness
so given some positive parameter
p which also usually will be at least
one
you can define rp in the following way
you take
x and y which are independent
and then you take their independent
copies so x
prime has the same distribution of x as
x
and this independent of x and the same
about y
prime and then you can
try to bound this expectation by this
expectation and you
ask what is the optimal constant r here
how small
r you can take so this type of question
uh comes from
late maybe not so late second half of
the 20th century
and pere anflo was one of the first and
perhaps the first person to study this
this type of inequalities in his study
of the geometry of
metric spaces and he called this
roundness and
this is a natural way to somehow
[Music]
inherit this naming for our
pulses so this is the parameter rp
and the last moduli will be
called the jp for jensen
and now it will be the supremum because
the constant stands on the left hand
side
on the on the small part we look for the
optimal j in this inequality
so that is a vector
valued random variable a random vector
with values in f
and actually in many applications the
set
that appears here will be exactly the
mixture of x and y
that appeared before but
we can also ask this question in general
for some
generic random vector set you assume
that this is integrable just
to give sense to expectation and you ask
what is the best constant
with which this inequality holds and you
call this jp
and by instance inequality obviously
this
always holds with j equal to one
so the question is can you strengthen
the jensen's inequality can you do
can you get the constant better than one
and now
let us observe that there are some
relations
bounding this moduli so one trivial
observation was that
bp is always not greater than mp
and another observation a bit less
trivial is that mp is always bounded by
two plus rp divided by two times jp and
now let me explain this
so you look at this expression this is
just
jp for x
and y this is expression of the type
that appears in the definition of
of m see
this is exactly this this type of
expression
so you take this and notice that this is
just twice
the expectation when you replace x and y
by z
this is just because that is mixture of
x and y
with weights one half then
you bound this
by this just by definition of the
parameter j
because you have this in a collision now
because you know that that is the
mixture of x and y
and z prime is a mixture of independent
x prime and y
prime you can easily write down this
expression
in terms of the distributions of
x y x x prime y y prime there are just
four cases and
two of them grew together to form this
and then you recall that you can bound
this expression with constant rp by this
expression by definition of the
roundness parameter okay
so putting things together you get
this inequality and of course may ask
about this roundness
constant why are you calling it
roundness is it the case that it's
minimized for hilbert space or something
of that sort
uh
yes no i'm not an expert in roundness
but basically
that was the parameter that the enflo
invented
to show that some metric spaces cannot
be embedded in some other metric spaces
so the way you do it is you prove that
some of them have this with nice
constant and
the other spaces don't have it and it's
called roundness because yeah
being included space for example gives a
good estimate for this parameter
but i'm not in a position to say whether
it's
optimal for human spaces or anything
like that perhaps
but i'm not an expert in in metal gear
so thanks but probably if you ask us of
now he will know in a second okay
i'm not just not doing this this type of
research so i i don't know at the moment
okay so now of course the interesting
question is
what can you say about these parameters
and they are interesting not only from
the point of view of the metric
or banach space geometry but also they
are interesting from probabilistic point
of view
they say something about symmetrizations
of random variables and
in many applications and probability
you want to replace for example
this type of centering of a random
variable
by this one and it's good to know
how small price you can pay for
replacing one with another so
this is a natural probabilistic question
as well appearing in
many applications so
we managed to establish the optimal
the exact values of some of those
parameters
for some uh particular
banner spaces so one example is lq space
just the labex space
of functions integrable with q's power
so
for jp we have the full
range of exact values so
whatever p and q you take from one
infinite
half line uh the jp can be expressed as
two in power
c where c is given by this formula okay
and we have examples showing that this
is optimal
and because there are four expressions
that can appear here
there are four quite different examples
showing
optimality of this bound in various
regimes in various relations between p
and q okay depending on what p and q
are you you have various examples
showing the optimality of this
and we managed to prove that with this
constant
the inequality always holds so for p and
q between 1
and 2 and when p is below q
we managed also to find exact values for
these parameters bp and mp
now for the roundness parameters we
managed to do in some special cases
so when p and q are between one and
infinity
and one of them is between
the other one and the conjugate are the
exponents
and also there is some additional
special case where we know
that the roundness parameter is equal to
two so of course i'm not going to
to show you the proof and of course
there is no hope for you to remember
what these parameters are
at the moment and what this means
but basically this is just to show you
that in quite many situations
you can find optimal constants
and besides those situations where we
can
prove that the bounds are optimal that
the
the values of these parameters are exact
we also
have some one-sided bounds which look
reasonable and work in more general
situation
outside these assumptions
but then we don't know whether they are
optimal or we have good reasons to
believe that they are not optimal
sometimes we conjecture
some better values but again
we don't have time to get into
technicalities
i would like just to give you some
sketch of the idea how
this thing is proved so the
idea comes from complex interpolation
so when you want to prove
such bound on the geometric moduli
for the space lq it's convenient to
express it as an interpolation space
between l2 and lq for some capital q
okay so when q small q is
bigger than 2 then capital q of course
also needs to be bigger than 2 and
possibly equal to infinity
when small q is between 1 and 2
this capital q is below 2 and possibly
equal to 1
in many situations it will be equal to
1. so the second point
is to choose the right operator
and it will go between
[Music]
this function spaces
and choosing the right operator is
important because later you want to
deduce something from
the interpolation bound that you will
get
and then you need to prove that this
operator that you choose
satisfies a simple l infinite
l infinity norm bound or
l one l one non-bound
and when i say that it's simple bound it
means
that you prove it using just the
triangle in the query
in all our atoms we are not able to
get any more sophisticated tool to deal
with this
this part of the estimate basically
because
you don't have any information about
about this lq space in most situations
that you could take advantage from
adventures of and then you
do another estimate which is usually
more subtle
and this is in hilbert situation you use
spectral methods
and you prove the norm bound normal
estimate
for l2 l2
okay so now this is a misleading
notation
this lq that is inside or l2 that is
inside here is a function space
and you look at the operator
that goes from this function space to
this function space
and to make things more difficult they
may live on different
measure spaces okay so this is our q on
some
measure space and this is lq on some
other measure space
and then you look at the l infinity l
infinity bound
for an vector operator going from this
vector space to this vector space
okay and for this and of course
everything
is needs to be complex banach spaces
and then you can use complex
interpolation so this is
like restoring the difference that is
that in the classical restoring
you have just complex valued functions
and here you have
vector valued functions and
and you need to use a bit more advanced
tools but
of course they are well known they exist
and and you just apply
the the reddit toolkit from the
interpolation
theory okay so now once you have
this l infinity and l2 and 2
bound you can use the interpolation
theory to get
lplq lplq norm bound
just by restoring equivalence for this
vector
valued space vector valued operators
now once you have this bound
you deduce from it some information
about the geometric modulus
so this is where the choice of the right
operators is important because
you need to choose it wisely in order to
be able to do this anything
here at the step four okay
now uh if you are lucky
you may manage to show example showing
that the bound that you obtain here on
the geometric modulus optimal
so in some situations we are lucky to
to prove that sometimes we think it's
not optimal
but if you are lucky you can prove this
then the next point is that
sometimes it works better
if you use the interpolation tweak not
from the
not for the module modules that you want
to estimate
but for other moduli and then
only after making interpolation you take
advantage
of some relation between moduli so let
me give you an
example so this red
inequality is one of the examples of the
interplay between moduli that you can
take advantage of
at this point and surprisingly it works
better
in many situations than using just
interpolation
for the modulus that you want to study
okay
so this is another thing
and then you still
want to improve the obtaining bounce in
some situations
and sometimes surprisingly you can do it
by some other tricks involving nonlinear
isometric embeddings
so there are some results showing how to
embed lq
into some lr
for some other exponent but not in a
linear fashion
but by using some power
power maps
that are non-linear but are isometric
and because all expression that you deal
with have the property that they are of
the distance type
all expressions here are just
metric type things measuring distance
between two things
there is no problem with the fact that
this is non-linear
and this non-linear isometric embeddings
may give you some extra power in many
situations so this is actually
if you look at the details of our paper
you will see that in some places
this non-linear isometric embeddings
actually allows you to get something
much better than
if you don't do that okay and
at the end i want to mention that the
same
idea may be exploited when you deal with
shutting classes
instead of lq okay so
this is non-commutative counterpoint of
lubbock spaces
and because you can express
the sq shutter class as an
interpolation between the hilbert space
and the
in s infinity the operator
no shutter class you can repeat the same
scheme of the proof the important thing
is that
in shutting classes for parameter 2 you
also have a hilbert
space situation and you can apply the
same spectral metals
approach and get also the results for
shutting classes so all this idea has a
shortened class counterpart
unfortunately
for certain classes many estimates that
are effective and optimal for labor
spaces
are no longer optimal and the question
is
what you should improve to get something
even better
in non-commutative setting but we didn't
manage to
to make any progress in this direction
so now let me just give a bit more
details about this interpolation picture
so you have some operator that you want
to bound
so this is this wisely chosen operator
that you
really want to estimate so you have some
function space lq
on some measure space on the right hand
side you have lq on some other measure
space sometimes it will be the same but
quite often it will be a different
measure space and then you want to
bounce
the operator t acting from here to here
and you want to bound its piece norm
okay so this is how you interpret this
this arrow and how you do that you
express
lq as an interpolation
between capital lq
and l2 with some parameter theta
and you do the same with l2 and
l infinity here you choose the data
so that both equalities that
come from this interpolation theory this
is very
restoring like that both of them are
satisfied
for the same setup and if you are able
to
find such theta in the interval 0 1 that
this is satisfied
then you can bound the norm of this
operator
as some geometric mean
of the norms of these operators and
the powers in this geometric mean
expression
uh are related with theta one of them
will be theta and the other one will be
one minus theta
okay and the similar trick works
when p is between one and two this
is what you do when p is between two and
infinite
and if p is between one and two you just
dualize the picture
and basically do the same replacing l
infinity by l one
the the same idea works okay and the
main caveat here
is that of course you have some freedom
you can
change this parameter theta and
capital q and when you play with these
two parameters trying to
to make things work together you must be
careful
because you cannot go with q above
infinity and you cannot go with q below
one
okay so this is the main reason for
different areas of applications of the
results that appear you notice that
there is some interplay between
parameters p and q if one of them is
greater or greater than
the other one
greater than conjugates to another one
or some other
relation between happens then you have
this bound
in other regime you have another about
and the reason the basic reason for the
results splitting into sub cases
is exactly this obstacle that you
you cannot do this trick
with q greater than infinity or below
one
okay and actually there is a good reason
for that
in many situations because what you get
just by stopping at the level of q equal
to infinite or q equal to one gives you
the optimal constant and you can show an
example
indicating that actually you cannot do
better so you are lucky
somehow the formalism stops you but it's
good that it stops you because
it gives you the optimal results okay
somehow the interpolation
theory does the job for you
okay and now let me just demonstrate
because all of this is quite vague
you didn't learn about what is this wise
choice of operator to to give anything
and i will just show you the simplest
example
how to choose this operator to make the
thing work
okay so let us start with this random
variable that
uh it is defined on some probability
space omega mu
and takes value in some hilbert space
okay so let's start with the hilbert
space valued operator
so now we have the space of
all h valued
functions eight eight valued
random vectors but defined on the
product space you take omega
product with omega with product measure
and then from this space of
all such random vectors you take the
orthogonal projection
to the closed linear space subspace of
functions
living in this space of a very special
form
this very special form is functions
of the form phi of x minus phi of y
where phi
is just function of one variable
okay so you look at the functions that
are symmetrizations
themselves and you project from the
whole space
to the linear close subspace of this
of this very special functions okay
so you can express s of f
as tf of x minus tf of y for some tf
and one can easily check that this tf
may be
explicitly expressed in terms of some
integral
you just integrate function f with
respect to the second coordinate
you average it with respect to first
coordinating take the difference
of this expectation one half of it and
this
this is an easy exercise that this
orthogonal projection
is given by function of this type
okay and here additionally you want
this function phi to have expectation
zero
because of course if you move it by
constant if you add constant
the difference will not change so just
to keep attention
to specific single function uh
you additionally assume that it has
expectations here
okay so then you can find tf
by this expression and actually you see
that this is linear
so this is our operator this is our
operator that we want to study
and now you see this leaves on a product
space
and what happens on the first coordinate
is independent from what happens on the
second coordinate
so if you will instead of looking at the
x and y you just
can speak about z and its independent
copies
and these are just independent random
variables okay
so they are orthogonal in l2 because of
the independence
so now we have this trivial inequality
this comes just from the fact that s is
the orthogonal projection so it doesn't
increase the l2 length of the
function now you know
that sf can be
written as this difference and now you
know that these
two summons are independent so
the squared norm of that is just
squared second norm of this plus square
second norm of this
this is just pythagorean theorem okay
because of the independence
and this is the wise way of
writing the dependence on the first
coordinate only
and here the dependence on the second
coordinator
so somehow this is more formal way of
writing
this thing here okay but now
you notice that because this doesn't
depend on the second coordinate and this
doesn't depend on the first coordinate
you can easily compute this just in
terms of what happens on the first
coordinate
okay so you managed
in this way to bound the l2 norm
of tf
which lives on
just a single omega in terms
of what happens to the function f on the
product space omega omega
okay so we have proved
this estimate okay we have bounded
the norm of operator t given by this
formula
by 1 over square root of 2.
okay but then we can look at the
operator given by
exactly the same formula but for
arbitrary banner space
so here we employed the fact that we
live in a hilbert space
and we could use orthogonality
but now for arbitrary banner space we
don't have
this spectral tools
so the only thing that we can do is just
the triangle in a collet
we very bluntly just estimating this
from above by the triangle inequality
observing that this norm is bounded by
one and this norm is bounded by one
and then we are in position to
interpolate
this is exactly part of the picture that
i showed you before
you have l2 on some measure space here
you have r2 on some other space
and here on the same probability spaces
you have
an infinite early infinity bound so we
can interpolate
between l2 and early infinity and here
you can interpolate between l1 and
l2 and in this way you get
exact values of jp
for arbitrary
choice of p and q between one and
infinite okay
so this is what i call the appropriate
choice of operator t for the purpose
of getting the bound because now we are
able to make the last
step and just use
this norm bound that we obtain between
lp and lp for a very specific function
so we have this here we have
constant that is strong smaller than one
this is some power of two
here we have some constant that is equal
to one so when we interpolate we have
we obtain some other power of two with
exponent that depends on p
and q in the way that i described few
slides
ago and then you apply this
lplp norm bound
for a very specific function f of x y
which is just random variables at point
x
minus that in point y
and you can easily see that for this
random variable
t f is simply z minus expectation of
that because
this expression cx minus 3y is the same
as cx minus expectation that
minus zy minus expectation z so
from the very beginning this function
lives in the subspace on which we
project it
so nothing will change and tf will be
exactly
the centered version of that and then
the interpolation bound
that you obtained here gives you exactly
the j inequality
that we are looking for you you bound
this expression by this
and the constant that you get luckily is
optimal here
okay so this was just to give you the
proof in the
simplest case for other modular
the proof is more complicated and i
don't want to get into details they are
written in the paper the paper is like
20 pages long and
i don't want to to borrow you here
with technicalities
it's more tricky with other modular you
need to
get some more complicated operators to
use some additional tweaks
to to get some interesting results
but basically the the main idea lying
behind this is this interpolation
machine and now just as a teaser to make
you
have a look into the paper
i will show you the following result
that is also contained here
so when you have a banner space that is
of real dimension at most three
the following bounds hold for arbitrary
random vectors and x and y you need to
assume something
about integrability just to give sense
to
to both sides of the inequality but once
you have
integrability the following bounds hold
true
okay and instead of assuming that the
dimension of the banana space is not
greater than three
you can assume for example that this is
hilbert space and also you get
this bounce and i cannot see
any easy reason why this is true
okay i i know of course how to prove it
but i think it's
a bit surprising that you have this type
of course this is some limit case
when you look at the peace powers and
tend with p to zero
okay so then you come to these type of
questions
technically they are more difficult
than the questions for p greater than
zero
uh you need to take care of the fact
that logarithm has two singularities
both in zero and in infinity and
this makes proofs much more complicated
and basically the idea allowing you to
prove this
comes from the very beautiful results by
carlton koldowski asking andy askina
that any three-dimensional banner space
as well as any hilbert space
embeds linearly into l0 and l0
here is understood as the function
space with the norm given by geometric
mean
okay so for a function you take
expectation of logarithm of
the absolute value of this function
assuming that it's integrable enough
and then you take expectation of this so
i put
isometrically in quotes signs because
of course zero here is not a metric
space
and actually it's so bad that you can
have two functions f and g
for which this l zero norm is equal to
zero
but the error sum f plus g has this l0
norm positive
okay so it's not only
it's not only the matter that it doesn't
satisfy the
triangular inequality it's not
quasimetric
but also it's so bad that the sum of two
elements
uh that have zero norm may have non-zero
now
but still you can give
some good meaning to
isometric embedding of the banach space
into l0
and the beautiful and difficult results
from harmonic analysis shows you that
you can do it always for three
dimensional spaces
and also an easy
fact is that hilbert spaces can be
embedded in l0
okay so thank you very much this is all
that i wanted to discuss
um
so any questions for kristoff
actually okay i'll ask a question um i
don't know if this is a very sensible
question but
you know with with discrete random
variables if uh if i want to have some
[Music]
sorry i mean there's a random variable
dependent i can
depend by looking at something like
mutual information
oh okay okay and i can
i can quantize just how dependent they
are right they can save their mutual
information
epsilon then the most independent so i'm
curious
is there a robust version of reversal in
the beginning where
if you somehow can bound quantitatively
the amount of dependence between x and y
you can still reverse it with maybe a
worse constant or something like that
okay i didn't hear a question in full
because i had some
sign some sound problems but i think i
understand
you ask whether you can relax the
independence assumption to some
sort of almost independence okay
and i think this is a very good question
this is a question how
much you need independence in all these
reasonings okay
and i don't know an answer to it and i
think it's worth studying
what is the natural condition replacing
independence in all this stuff
still allowing you to reverse the
inequalities this is a very good
question
uh and i'm pretty sure that you can
relax independence the question is
is there some natural condition that
that works as well but
i i was wondering this actually at your
first slide though but i was thinking
more just late in correlation on one by
absolute value if you like correlation
to b but what do you mean by correlation
if they are in banach space
of course they are on real random
variables you can
say what correlation means but in banner
space
i mean you can define you can look at
the norm i guess
look at the correlation of the norms
that's probably too little perhaps you
can look
at all linear functionals and ask about
correlation of
phi of x phi of y for any
linear functional phi for example
something like that perhaps
but no i i think that would be too weak
i i don't have any ready counter example
but
i think that it doesn't
seem likely this correlation thing would
work well for the hilbert
regime for p equal to two per baby
and for hilbert space but i don't see
any reason why
it should work for other powers and
other vector spaces i
i don't think that that's the correct
way of looking at that
i i think your questions are very
natural and
i don't know any good answer and i think
that's one of the reasons
why this is worth studying this question
because
uh as i said in the beginning the
question is
you want to somehow margarize
having a distribution of x and
distribution of y you try to understand
in what position you should put in them
to get the maximal
or up to constant maximal value of of
this
type of expression okay and the answer
is that they are independent this is
basically what's what our results show
and the question is what you can
do instead of independence and of course
if you can do this with
condition different from independence
then
again you have two-sided inequalities
going both directions so this means that
such condition would be
basically equivalent to independence in
terms of this modularization okay
so this is a very natural question a
very good one and i don't have any idea
what
this condition should look like i think
this is a very good question
but maybe it's hopeless i i just don't
know
maybe maybe some mutual information
something like that as
germany said but i i don't know
um if i have a comment and a question
kristoff
comment is i think uh part of what
jalani was saying
um i couldn't hear it completely either
but
if you look at discrete random variables
uh
are there inequalities like this using
mutual information which is another way
of
comparing how
independent or non-independent there
right okay so you say that
there is something that is already known
uh in this direction
oh i think i think jalani was i'm sorry
i guess
some of my question maybe it wasn't hurt
yeah i mean so i mean i know examples
you know that have nothing to do with
these kinds of uh expectations of norms
but just
equal you know let's say that you know
something is true for independent random
variables if you bound the mutual
information can you still say something
i do know examples of that that don't
look anything like this
so i was just curious whether in this
particular example
uh there's some quantization of
dependence
that can like robustify the theorem i
think this is a very good and natural
question but
i don't know an answer to it and i will
be glad to
to know something more about about that
but it may be difficult
i have another quick question christoph
so for the general bounds you mentioned
between m
and b bp and mp and r
uh so those are the only general bounds
for every bonus face f
there is no well up to some other
constants depending on maybe
p and so on can you reverse some of
those uh
[Music]
i think this study is very far from
complete
so we tried to optimize in the direction
where we knew
what we were doing right where things
work smoothly
but we are far from having
you know full set of relations between
these concepts
they are interesting geometric moduli
and one of the reasons we didn't
go too much into this abstract nonsense
is the fact
that we still don't know what is bp or
even b1
of little l infinity okay l
infinity is not separable so think about
high dimensional but finite dimensional
little l infinity okay you say
you take just a high dimensional cube
and we don't have any idea
what b1
what this basic question what the answer
to this basic question
with exponent one is in this case okay
if we get this uh additional cutting
with
hyperplane then we know but
even for l infinity we don't know a
thing
and if you don't know how to answer such
very simple questions somehow getting
too much into abstract
interplay between these parameters
probably is not the not the good choice
probably first
one should understand the the basic
examples and
and even here in many situations we
don't have
a hint what the answer is
and for all p for b sub p you have the
same
same construction that shows the
tightness yes
yes so in this bound this is basically
the same
the same construction and the only thing
that
differs in the proof is that once you
use just the ends and inequality for the
norm when p is equal to one
and if p is greater than one you just
use the convexity of the norm in power p
but the underlying structure is the same
thanks basically and
perhaps it's interesting to know that
for p greater than 1 you can ask the
same question
in the language of metric spaces instead
of the banner spaces okay
all three terms that appear here can be
expressed in terms of
the metric distance between x and z y
and z
x and y and we can answer this question
about the optimal constant
if you replace boundary spaces by metric
spaces
it's a different from this one
if p is greater than one then these two
bounds match for p equal to one
and somehow the metric space case is
trivial compared to what happens in
banach space
somehow it's not very difficult to prove
the optimal constant
to invent what it is and also to prove
the optimality
somehow the metric question here is much
easier than
what happens in banner space
all right thanks a lot i think we're
actually we're running into the next
speaker so let's uh thank you
thanks and